המחשבים-על הקלאסיים הטובים ביותר שלנו הולכים ונעשים חזקים יותר,
ואנחנו משתפרים בחישוב, כולל סימולציה של מערכות.
אבל לסמלץ את הטבע זה בעיה ממש קשה בכלל.
שמי Victoria Lipinska והיום נחקור אחד האלגוריתמים
שיכולים לאפשר סימולציה של הטבע על מחשב קוונטי.
בוא נתחיל עם דוגמה ונסתכל על קפאין.
זה מולקולה פשוטה.
כדי לייצג את תצורת האנרגיה של מולקולת קפאין אחת בלבד,
נצטרך בערך עשר בחזקת 48 ביטים.
זה עשר עם 48 אפסים
וזה בערך 10% ממספר האטומים בכדור הארץ.
ובעצם זה עוד יותר גרוע.
אם יש לך 125 אורביטלים ואתה רוצה לאחסן את כל התצורות האפשריות,
אתה צריך יותר זיכרון
במחשב הקלאסי שלך ממספר האטומים ביקום.
זה בלתי אפשרי לייצג עם מחשבי-על.
יש תקווה למחשבים קוונטיים, אבל,
כי הם בטבעם טובים בסימולציה של הטבע.
עבור מולקולת קפאין, זה אומר לייצג
את המערכת באמצעות 160 qubits.
זה נשמע הרבה יותר ניתן לניהול.
הוצעו אלגוריתמים קוונטיים שונים שמאפשרים
למחשבים קוונטיים קטנים יותר לסמלץ את הטבע בצורה היוריסטית.
הכנסו: variational quantum eigensolver או VQE.
VQE הוא אלגוריתם שרץ בחלקו על מחשב קוונטי
ובחלקו על מחשב קלאסי.
הוא מאפשר לנו למצוא ערכים שפותרים בעיית אופטימיזציה נתונה.
VQE קשור מאוד לשיטות אחרות שכוללות
וריאציה של פרמטרים כמו quantum approximate optimization algorithm.
לזהות יישומים של VQE בתעשייה שלך או במחקר שלך
זה סוג של אמנות, אבל יש הנחיות כלליות.
בדרך כלל, VQE מתאים לבעיות שאפשר לנסח
כבעיית אופטימיזציה עם משתנים רציפים.
זה המצב, למשל, בהרבה מהכימיה הקוונטית.
לעתים קרובות מאוד, בכימיה, אנחנו מתעניינים במצב הבסיס.
מצב הבסיס הוא המצב עם האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר של המערכת.
כדי למצוא את אנרגיית מצב הבסיס, VQE חוקר
את האנרגיה עבור תצורות שונות של המערכת
ומחפש את תצורת האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר.
ברמה גבוהה, VQE מקבל תיאור של המערכת הקוונטית
ומחפש את האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר.
הוא עושה זאת על ידי שינוי תצורת המערכת.
להתחלה, עלינו להזין תיאור מתאים של המערכת
שהמחשב הקוונטי מבין וקבוצת פרמטרים שמתארים אותה
שיעברו אופטימיזציה.
החלק הקוונטי של
האלגוריתם מכין את המערכת במצב
המתואר על ידי קבוצת פרמטרים נתונה ומחשב את האנרגיה.
בעוד שהחלק הקלאסי אחראי
על אופטימיזציה של אותם פרמטרים בכל שלב.
התהליך הקוונטי-קלאסי הזה חוזר על עצמו
עד שנגיע לאנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר.
עכשיו בוא נתקרב ונסתכל מה קורה מתחת למכסה המנוע.
תצורת האנרגיה מתוארת בדרך כלל ב-Hamiltonian
ובדרך כלל זה מטריצה ממש גדולה.
באלגברה, כדי למצוא את הערך העצמי הנמוך ביותר של המטריצה
שמתאים לאנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר של המערכת,
היינו פשוט עושים פירוק ערכים סינגולריים.
אבל המטריצות שנסתכל עליהן הן גדולות אקספוננציאלית
וזו בעיה קשה אקספוננציאלית לעשות זאת אלגברית.
ה-Hamiltonian הזה צריך להיות מיוצג בצורה
שהמחשב הקוונטי יכול להבין.
כלומר, מתורגם משפת הכימיה לשפת המחשוב הקוונטי.
אל תדאג לגבי הפרטים.
בסופו של דבר יש דרכים שאפשר לתכנת אותן לתרגם את ה-Hamiltonian בדרך כלל
כפי שנראה בכימיה ל-Hamiltonian שמחשב קוונטי יכול להבין.
אנחנו מזינים את ה-
Hamiltonian הזה יחד עם ה-circuit, שאנחנו קוראים לו variational form.
בחירת variational form היא סוג של אמנות.
שוב,
הוא מייצג את הניחוש הטוב ביותר שלנו לגבי מה שיכול להיות המצב הקוונטי של המערכת.
ה-circuit הוריאציוני הזה מפורמטר עם קבוצת פרמטרים theta,
ואנחנו גם מזינים בחירה ראשונית של הפרמטרים האלה.
על בסיס זה, החלק הקוונטי של VQE:
מכין את מצב הייחוס, למשל, מצב האפס;
משתמש ב-circuit קוונטי מפורמטר, ה-variational form, להכנת מצב קוונטי
עבור ניחוש ראשוני של פרמטרים על המחשב הקוונטי; והוא מעריך
את האנרגיה שמתאימה למצב שהוערך דרך ה-Hamiltonian.
הערכת האנרגיה הזו מוזנת אז
למייעל הקלאסי, שמוצא קבוצת פרמטרים חדשה.
הפרמטרים מוצאים את דרכם חזרה לפותר הקוונטי שוב,
והתהליך כולו חוזר על עצמו.
המחשב הקוונטי מוצא הערכת אנרגיה חדשה,
המייעל הקלאסי מוצא קבוצת פרמטרים חדשה וכן הלאה.
אנחנו חוזרים על התהליך הזה עד שהפתרון מתכנס.
כלומר עד שההפרש בתוצאות בין השלבים קטן מספיק
לצרכים שלנו.
בסוף, האלגוריתם מחזיר את האנרגיה הממוזערת הזאת.
אוקיי, זה מעולה.
אבל אולי תתהה איך אנחנו יודעים שזה באמת עובד
ושלא נמצא בטעות אנרגיה נמוכה ממה שאנחנו מחפשים?
זו שאלה מצוינת.
מסתבר שאנחנו לעולם לא יכולים להעריך אנרגיה שהיא נמוכה יותר.
זה בזכות משהו שאנחנו קוראים לו עיקרון הוריאציה.
עיקרון הוריאציה קובע שהחסם התחתון הגדול ביותר
על האנרגיה של המערכת הוא תמיד
האנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר שמתאימה למצב הבסיס הזה.
זה אומר שאנרגיה שמוערכת על כל מצב אחר של אותה מערכת
תהיה תמיד גדולה מהאנרגיה הנמוכה ביותר.
לכן, עם VQE אנחנו לעולם לא יכולים לקבל משהו
נמוך מאנרגיית מצב הבסיס.
אבל, אנחנו אכן יכולים להתכנס למשהו
גדול מהמינימום שאנחנו מחפשים.
זה נקרא לעתים קרובות פתרון מטסטבילי
וזו אתגר שחוקרים מנסים לפתור על בסיס יומיומי.
VQE שימושי כי הוא משתמש ב-circuits רדודים יותר
בהשוואה לפרוטוקולים אחרים שמאפשרים לנו להעריך אנרגיית מצב בסיס.
זה הופך אותו למתאים לחומרה קוונטית לטווח קצר.
בסרטון הזה הצצנו למה VQE יכול לעשות ואיך הוא בנוי.
אבל אני ממליצה לך לחקור את Qiskit בהקשר הזה.
למרות שאנחנו עדיין בתחילת המסע הקוונטי שלנו,
אולי תמצא את זה כבר שימושי לבעיות שאתה מנסה לפתור.
שמי Victoria Lipinska וזה היה סקירה כללית
של אלגוריתם ה-variational quantum eigensolver.